ladies and gentlemen welcome to the Tim
Dillon show live from the greatest city
in the world Nashville Tennessee here
with the voice of country music Giannis
Papas old friend of mine are you
watching Dahmer on Netflix man I haven't
watched it uh but I just want to say
hello to my fans and uh Trump 2024
everybody yeah yeah isn't it that is a
great archetype of person be like that
sweet country guy yeah who just talks
about his fan like I love all my fans
because you see them on uh social media
and it's it's another it's one of the
many people I wish I could be yeah
they're very nice and kind in the South
and because the other side is just yeah
it's just violent racism
hey y'all I love my fans I love you all
thank you all for supporting me and
being there for me and it's just a nice
you know it's my daughter and they hold
up their daughter they're like this is
my special girl yeah you know and then
and then the camera goes off and they go
you know Kanye West has a little bit of
a point
I'm confused because you know I like
that he's speaking out I might not agree
with everything but I like that he's
talking but most most of it this uh this
Dahmer thing is huge because as it is
very hot it's this guy who is just
taking advantage of people he is
bringing them home he's getting it done
um it is hot didn't he do them a little
bit of a favor though they're in
Milwaukee it's the deal it's a good way
to exit Milwaukee and the deal is
everybody is kink shaming him because we
live in a CIS hat nightmare but this is
a guy who early on his Kinks were like
taking pigs home from uh biology and
dissecting them in his room and that
evolved into people and uh but he's cool
you know the the thing does kind of like
Dahmer's dad is suing
Netflix for glorifying his son
this is true yeah because it is cool
when you look at the thing when you're
watching it you're like Dahmer's kind of
hot yeah he's kind of cool he does some
things we don't agree with but overall
who doesn't who does it overall he's a
likable
hot dude who's like get just on on the
Journey of like getting his confidence
and
and people want to be him for Halloween
this is how much it succeeded
people want to be Dahmer for Halloween
and now Amazon has stopped uh selling
the Dahmer costumes because Simone biles
among other is the gymnast who couldn't
perform because she was sad
um she the one who dropped out of the
Olympics she is like telling everybody
don't you dare come showing up his
Dahmer because he did kill a lot of
young men and boys of color yeah but not
you know the person showing up is Dahmer
didn't that's always lost it's just a
costume party yeah it's uh that's always
lost on people yeah
I mean you know what's the big deal yeah
I mean if uh if Prince what's his name
prince prince Andrew what's his name the
the one who's married to Megan Merkel
Harry the bimbo Andrews the Pito yeah if
Harry came to my costume party and he
was dressed as Adolf I'm not stopping
the party I'm not telling him to change
costume yeah he's not Adolf it's
insensitive yes but I don't invite Jews
to my parties the point is and how do
you get away with that New York to get
in anyway you do it you do it with the
DNA test yeah you're doing the fairy you
say it's covered but it's really you
drop a little money on the floor if they
chase it you can't come out yeah well
that's edited it out huh Adidas won't be
doing your shoe no you just yeah I take
off the hat check for horns none go does
he come back from this Kanye probably
not right this is now this is too far
he's gone a little too far that's why
I'm enjoying it because he doesn't want
to come back yeah that is the most fun
to watch I mean we've seen the kind of
things and then people apologize yeah
he's so avant-garde he's like I'm not
doing the apology he's going y'all gonna
have to kill me that's right let's go
Jews people gonna have to kill me and if
you kill me guess what there'll be
another Kanye born in another ghetto in
Chicago saying the same [ __ ] and we
gotta me to these Jews what do you do to
someone who's at that point kill him in
there they they there's not much else
you can do right you got to take them
out because he's having such a public
meltdown and he has so many fans and so
many followers we're of course obviously
it needs not to be said or not
advocating this but there has got to be
people going like he's a problem
yeah but do you think they're going he's
a problem or he's so out there that it's
not a problem well it's not that he's a
problem like in the sense that he's
going to like Galvanize people against
the Jews right I just mean he's a
problem like how bad does this get
publicly
how when does he stop getting the
platforms maybe this is it right like
when does he stop getting massive
mainstream attention when does that go
away when did they go okay yes we want
the views yes we want the clicks but
he's he's going too far yeah is it flat
earth like what what stop on the train
is when they pull back well that's a you
don't want to do that analogy here stop
on the train
right I don't even yeah I wasn't even
think about it stop on the boat stop on
the boat
um yeah I think as soon as he buys
parlor
and he starts he starts voicing his
opinions on parlor because I think
that's what you do now is you just you
say something crazy and then you just as
a billionaire and then you buy a
conservative social media site and then
nobody cares anymore you're gonna have
to have a billion dollars just to speak
and you know what he's not even gonna
enjoy parlor what he enjoys he's right
he's an attention guy right he likes the
attention so he likes shocking people
but when he goes on parlor after he buys
parlor and he's like Jews run the world
and everyone's going yeah yeah this is
no fun no it's that's an echo chamber
and that's what you're gonna need you're
gonna need a couple of billion to really
get wild like we used to be able to get
wild after a few drinks and you still
can at the local pub but if you want to
get wild publicly now you're gonna have
to have billions of dollars you do have
to have billions because you're gonna
have to buy an app that will allow you
to be racist yeah
yeah you have to purchase you have to
have a company now you used to be able
to just be racist now you have to have a
company with like secretaries and
Executives and AD sales people you're
gonna have to have a monetization
strategy just to go out and be racist
yeah yeah that's the level we're at
there's no more poor poor racism anymore
racism is going to cost you yeah it's
gonna cost you a lot of money yeah and
paranoia is going to cost Alex Jones
965 billion dollars for Sandy Hook yeah
I just can't I don't understand why
they're trying to stop all the
entertainment I mean how much are those
kids worth
I mean you could have killed me for
nothing yeah
yeah he doesn't have it to pay it no one
has it's a symbolic number nobody yeah
can really pay that in the media sphere
right it's a symbolic number it's just
to kind of get people to shut up yeah
it's kind of when they give somebody
multiple life sentences you're going
like all right I guess when I have
multiple lives you know right how is
this
symbolic I'm not Hindu this isn't
relevant do you remember when Dahmer got
popped because you you've been around
yeah I'm 80. so when when Dahmer got
popped do you remember this being a big
deal was this a media circus it was a
media circus yeah we love serial killers
it's almost
um unfortunate that they've been kind of
put out of business by DNA and yeah and
the surveillance date the uh you know
well serial killers now just go on
parlor they go in parlor there's no they
never get to the actual hard work of
stalking and killing yeah they just pop
off well we have I think they mutated
into School shooters oh interesting
Incarnation is that's it your theory
yeah because you know it's like it's a
star that we make them Stars right so
it's like you know someone's gonna wanna
walk down that red carpet that's right
of blood and it's somebody who can get
the you know it's kind of an immediate
result immediate overnight as opposed to
a serial killer who has to go through
this process for a very long time you
don't have to do Conan you don't have to
do a half hour right you go straight to
fame yeah what are the True Crime
podcasts gonna do because we know all
these sick [ __ ] who love they just
love the idea of people getting stalked
and killed yeah and they talk about it
endlessly and they make the families
relive all this trauma my favorite
murder uh Georgia and Karen all the time
they won't stop even when the families
ask them to stop they're like please we
don't need this they do kind of exactly
what Alex Jones did which is they get
everybody revved up to like crack let's
crack the Cold Case right
um what are they gonna talk about now
that she serial killers are done how are
they going to manipulate people's trauma
and grief for uh ad sales they're just
gonna have to go to war crimes podcasts
that might be interesting yeah there's a
little war crimes podcast but that's not
cool because that's not sexy enough like
they really want it's like a woman who's
jogging alone or a woman who went on two
dates with a guy then ended up in a
trunk like they really like that type of
because because the women listening are
usually women who are are in desperate
need of that their dream is to get raped
and killed yeah the women listening to
those podcasts their dream is to have
someone love them enough to stalk rape
and kill them that is all they want all
they want to do is hear that window
slide in the middle of the night yeah
and they get they start like going and
they want somebody to run up and
chloroform them and no one that night
after night nobody does it's another
empty it's another trip to the fridge at
2 30 in the morning with no chloroform
nobody's trying to kill you nobody cares
but that's what they that's why they
like those podcasts so much yeah you're
right most most women live most women
just live that's right about ignored
ignored ignored yeah ignored so when
people see
Dahmer and when I watch Dahmer what's so
interesting maybe the ladies feel left
out maybe because he was only focusing
on gays subconsciously the ladies are
like upset well also some of the ladies
are like so what this is being a woman
every day you know because that's the
new attitude like they're like getting
eaten chased by cannibals that's being a
woman 24 chef
that's what it's like to be a woman oh
finally oh is it disturbing that a
Cannibal's drugging and eating you how
about you try being a woman for
literally 15 minutes try being a woman
that has an idea in a meaning full of
men for literally 15 minutes it is
essentially having your liver eaten by a
cannibal in Milwaukee that is also part
of some of the attitude I see now yeah
no it's not a bit it's not such a huge
deal it's tough It's really tough it is
disturbing to watch though because he
brings these guys up to his thing and he
drugs them and they're like trying to
get out and they're stumbling around I
mean you know it's a little bit of a
Halloween episode here I have the Great
Pumpkin on and you're dressed like some
type of costume but this is your real
thing you know I don't know what this is
Danny Zuko I don't know what you're
doing or what the point of it is but
whatever it is it's called Arrested
Development
I should have on khakis and no idea
Merrell Shoes yeah and glasses yeah you
you live in this beautiful thing you
have this beautiful family and you're
out here dressed like I don't even know
you got money on your street or
something you're collecting numbers but
he some people need a very bad end in
America yeah and that's what I thought
about watching Dahmer I said some people
meet a very very bad and and I don't
mean like some of our friends where
they're just accused of rape after a
pretty good career
I mean like a bad end like they go out
one night and it just doesn't it they
think it goes gonna go one way and it
goes the other way yeah but it's rare I
mean you know if you get selected there
is some sort of uh you should sort of
feel special a little bit you were
selected it's a rare selection yes it's
a small club that gets eaten by Jeffrey
Dahmer do you know any most people in
Milwaukee just [ __ ] eat mayonnaise
and die that's diabetes yeah yeah yeah
they don't make the movies do you know
anyone that this has happened to or
something cool do you know anyone who's
left the planet in a way that's a little
cool well we both do it I wouldn't say
it was cool but horrific what do you
mean
especially since the restaurant's been
discombobulated since yeah well that's
great I mean that's random yeah kind of
but I mean like I don't know anyone you
grew up with that ended up getting uh
murdered yeah let me just uh sift
through my brain to see if I know anyone
we knew a guy who could eat it killed a
girl under a bridge but we didn't really
know him and we didn't really know her
but it was in my town but we didn't know
either of them but people I knew had met
them yeah it's a real not really a great
but I'm just saying I don't know because
you you know grew up in Brooklyn you
have this whole storied
but you wonder if anybody I can't think
of anyone who's been eaten yeah we're
not eating but just killed by cereal
what is your what if you what's your
fear that's like a horror movie Fear uh
you personally not your family nothing I
mean just like you what was your fear
when you were younger when you were
growing up what I mean you've been shot
right yeah yeah so you kind of you've
been there but what was the thing that
really
you like got you scared
um or as a white man does nothing scare
you would nothing scare you it's a
pretty smooth flight right I gotta say
it's a space not a lot of turbulence
yeah it's a pretty smooth flight well
that scares me airplanes airplanes are
scary I get scared because I'm not in
control yeah no but I was always scared
of uh being killed yeah
you know because there was just like
robbers and Killers everywhere right
yeah so you just growing up in New York
at the time was not fun there's
something about the Midwest where I've
been there I've performed in these
places Milwaukee Omaha all these and
there's something about it that is oddly
a cult right it feels evil it feels like
there's underground things going on it
feels like the people there there's more
than more to them than meets the eye
that there's some like
strange things happening cult cult-like
well they're all steak and ties they're
also Germanic there's a lot of Germanic
people but there's dramatic people
everywhere I know but the Germanic
people have it in them yeah you watch
their porn
you look at their history you you
perform comedy for them they're very
cerebral they're very rational but that
also leads to rationalization they're uh
they're missing a little piece of
humanity I think that's what happened in
World War II yeah I think they were
going like finally someone someone gave
us a purpose yeah they want to do it
they want to do it yeah the Germans want
to do it they want to do it they want to
do it you mean the Holocaust that's
exactly you know I didn't want to say it
I don't want to get demonetized for you
yeah but yeah they want they have a
thing in them where you know it's like
it's in there like I have a gay G I'm
Greek like I can unlock it right if I go
to prison I'll pick it up it's in there
right culturally through generations the
Germans have like the Irish with booze
exactly you unlock it yeah yeah like if
you're Irish and you have a drink
there's a good chance you might have
another and then have another and then
your wife's on the floor yeah with the
Germans you hit one you hit one slav
yeah next thing you know it just opens
the door and you want to just kill them
all when you know this this idea that um
people shouldn't go uh dressed up as a
character like Jeffrey Dahmer to
Halloween yeah is this something you
subscribe to do you when you you have a
child are you gonna really be heavily
involved in the decisions are you gonna
be like the typo like helicopter copter
parent who goes hey this is appropriate
this is not well if it's a kids
Halloween party you really shouldn't
show up as Jeffrey Dahmer
it's a fun if you
dresses Jeffrey Dahmer that's kind of
fun it's funny yeah it's a little that's
funny yeah um no I think the Halloween
party should that's your time I was you
know what I was when I was a kid
following a serial killer
generic one a generic here's what I did
I took a big my aunt made me a box and
we put all kinds of Lucky Charms on it
and we glued them to the box and I ate
them during trick-or-treating I would
just eat them off my thing and almost
get sick because they were covered in
glue I just wanted to be a carbohydrate
for Halloween but I was a serial kill it
was a fun way to be a a dark thing
that's fun right I could see yeah well
now I just like whatever my wife gets me
as a costume on Amazon that's what I'm
gonna be yeah I think I'm gonna be a
bubble guppy or something like that when
you have a kid you just are pulled into
that world and you just start doing kid
stuff and it's a family costume it's a
family costume she's a family yeah she's
one person in it I'm the other one and
I'm the other one yeah it's weird if
like a single guy shows up to a family
Halloween as a baby costume I would
actually almost be more comfortable if
he was Jeffrey Dahmer than say like yeah
I don't know Frozen uh the guy from
Frozen yeah you're going like why do you
know about Frozen yeah the only people
we should know about Frozen should have
kids if you don't if you don't have kids
I know about it because my cousin wrote
the [ __ ] music till there you have it
[ __ ] two e-gots what are you gonna do
yeah but if you're just a guy who knows
children's stuff you're going like it's
strange strange it's strange I love that
I'm only three or four episodes into the
Dahmer thing but it's like it's really
interesting how somebody grows up to be
accountable
this is something that's really
interesting because it is this weird
psychosexual thing that happens in your
head
you don't know how it had like the
mother was very weird and she was very
Naggy and anxious and the dad was a
little nuts but how do you create a
cannibal it's so difficult can our
producer here for the moment get up any
information on like how are cannibals
created yeah well they said he had
something that's uh I can't remember the
medical term for it but he was attracted
to the shiny the shininess of the organs
like there's some there's actually a
term for it where people are attracted
to shiny stuff and they believe it's
like evolutionary somehow well it's very
interesting I never even thought organs
were shiny yeah when you pull them out
they they go they glean a little bit
really yeah they don't they're not it's
not like the same as bling but they have
a glean to them interesting and he was
kind of drawn to that he was drawn to
that they say that was his sexual
oriented is that the worst nightmare to
raise a child who's accountable yeah I'd
say so
because when they sit Dahmer's dad down
and they're like he's gay and then
damage I was like oh no and then they're
like hold on I just like the way they
did the family apology very Midwestern
too oh Dad I'm sorry and he's like I
love you son
I mean if my dad found out I was eating
people he just would he would say that's
not my son kill him shoot him son I love
you son it's okay well you know it's
that's what I mean but there's something
going on out there where people go
that's just something that happens yeah
it's not it's completely out of you know
the realm of possibility because life is
so mind-numbingly boring out there yeah
that's what it is it's corn fields it's
mind-numbingly boring
people's inner lives can get away from
them out there and some people are
thinking about like what if instead of
eating a steak I eat a person yeah try
something different tonight that's why
how many times can you go to Red Lobster
how many times and I think that that's
part of what makes that area so
interesting is that there's a monotony
there's a monotony to life everywhere
but out there it's so plain and the
scenery is so plain and so vast that
people's minds start playing tricks with
them and they start going like maybe I
will try to do something yeah I think
you gotta be a psychopath I think you're
born I don't think there's any level of
bad nurture that makes you want to eat
somebody I think you're born with like a
bad brain you know it's like you just
have no empathy you're very calculated
you're very premeditated I mean look at
the way he did it he he uh he chose
certain people he knew he chose people
he knew cops would look the other way
yes if they found them on the street
naked with a bleening and this and a
hole in their head right have you gotten
to that scene yet I have I mean
what is the test to be a cop I stare I
mean back then is there a chapter on
there that says hey if a guy's uh he's
barely conscious his asshole's bleeding
he's naked in the street and there
happens to be a drilled hole in his head
you may not want to just peruse the
scene and leave but you know what it is
it really does go back to the idea that
Dahmer was like this Midwestern white
guy and they felt kind of like bad from
they'd say things like what are you
doing living here yeah like these are
all drug addicts why are you here and
more than more often than not they look
the other way you know he gave him the
excuse he was pulled over he's like yeah
you know my parents got divorced it's
been kind of a tough time they're like
ah everybody goes through stuff and it
was homophobic there was homophobia
involved yes I think they were just like
whoa I don't want to see the picture
whatever you guys are doing this is how
you guys do it right here yeah I don't
want to get AIDS yeah from walking in
the apartment yeah so it is there was a
lot of that that he used to his
Advantage he was kind of a very smart
guy that's what I'm saying it's like
sharp he's Psychopathic premeditated he
he selected his victims you can tell for
that purpose you know he was dissecting
I mean at least he could you know new
one-on-one Anatomy he could pass an
entry level causing Anatomy yeah he knew
where a liver was
no he knew a lot of stuff I mean again
it's one of those guys where it's like
you watch this thing you're trying to
hate him it's hard good job Netflix it's
very difficult to hate him here I'm
telling you you watch other things and
it's easy to hate the person there's
something tough here because you're like
he's experiencing
so many things that are running through
his head you can hate him yeah they
portrayed him as sort of a lonely a
loner his mom was mean to him he's
figuring it out yeah a coming-of-age
story that's what it feels like feels
like a coming to age it's like a fun gay
coming-of-age story he's got his shirt
off all the time and occasionally he
eats someone's kidney it's not it's sexy
it's kind of fun it's like Netflix was
like let's make something hot yeah it
and let's make something fun it's like a
young adult why a movie with cannibalism
well it's so unlike the entertainment
industry in Hollywood too right make
something like this
it's really not their yeah modus
operandi usually they take those things
into consideration they don't want to be
exploited exploitative they don't
they're so good usually they usually I
mean what are so sweet I think they
waited at what like five or six weeks
before the first 9 11 movie yeah so I
mean they're usually more you know
sensitive about these things
no why the dahmers are like dude you're
glorifying my son because I'm like
he's kind of like an anti-hero yeah in
this thing you're like Batman in the new
Batman yeah it's like Tony Soprano
Walter White Jeff Dahmer
you want him to win you don't want him
to get caught you know when the cops get
him you have this weird feeling you're
like I don't really want him to get
caught right I want him to keep doing
what he has to do yeah you know it's
funny because he Psychopaths lie all the
time yes they don't use the truth so
it's almost like Hollywood made the
movie that he would have liked yes
portraying the version of himself that
he created after he got caught but then
you hear stories about him in jail and
how he used to uh like he would um you
know he would uh uh you know chastise
people by making his food look like
organs and make noises and stuff like
that he would uh you know he's not he's
not a nice guy oh interesting but I
didn't know that he seems in this movie
kind of just like ripped he would taunt
people yeah oh he but he seems like more
ripped in this and like kind of like
just figuring out who he is in the world
and it's not easy for a young man at any
age to figure it out that's what I get
yeah that's what I think Netflix's
intent is and I'm like fully on board
with that where I watch it and I go this
is a guy who's really coming into his
own right that's what it feels like to
me coming of age yeah yeah totally
coming into his own uh yeah I mean you
know they portray can it be hot is it
okay for it to be attractive I mean is
it okay for an attractive guy to be
lifting weights and be attractive even
though he's maybe killing people it was
very hot until he hit him with the
dumbbell well but even that there's an
element there of hotness right because
he's taking back his his uh I don't even
know what the word is but he's like
taking his you know he's like taking the
narrative back well the guy the guy
rejected him I'm not like that the guy's
like very like straight toxic and also
homophobic and then yeah he's like an LG
tbq hero that comes in and they just hit
some mashes homophobia and he wasn't
trying to kill him he was just trying to
subdue him right yeah right and that's
what I like is that uh Netflix's version
this show kind of is sympathetic to his
version of events I feel like maybe they
let Weinstein like produce this on the
low could be yeah it feels like with
things that are getting good again it
feels like the me too Crews coming back
yeah because this is exactly what
something should be you're like am I
horrified am I aroused this is where
good movies live am I accountable this
is what you want people saying to
themselves in the suburbs while they
watch this and eat Panera
yeah I want to confuse people you win
and this is what movies used to do
before everything was like this is right
and this is wrong right now it's like oh
my God it's a big gray area what's going
on yeah they definitely were sympathetic
to his version of what happened the two
instances I'm thinking about is the one
murder in the hotel room he goes I don't
remember I don't remember I just woke up
and he was beaten to death yeah and I
remember and then the other one where he
hit the guy with the dumbbell he goes he
goes I was I didn't mean to hurt him
I didn't mean to hurt him I was just
trying to you know wake him up with a
dumbbell to the face right and they're
going like I guess he's telling the
truth yes that's because that's the
version of the show where it's like
that's not true at all he beat that guy
to death in the hotel room because he's
a psychopath and then he smashed that
guy in the head because he he couldn't
wait to get to the dead body part he
didn't like having sex with live people
because they moved he's like people
moving odd fetish necrophilia well
people can be a drag with their needs
and their walks it's a great Point
really they can't it's a great Point
yeah it's a very gr it's and you know
what it's not made enough you know it's
like you want well they look back at
podcasting one day as this insane like I
wonder how they look back at all this
like well they make a Dahmer movie but
about this like well they just look back
and go there was a point in our history
where people just talked for hours and
hours and hours endlessly with no facts
really nothing to back any of it up at
best case they guessed about things
worst case they completely made it up uh
they they were everybody from comedians
to [ __ ] journalists to writers to
just Common Street people and they would
just get on the microphone and just
pontificate about things knowing nothing
about them you wonder if at some point
they look back on this and they go that
was damaresque
like do they do they look back on this
and go like there's endless endless
hours of these [ __ ] idiots talk like
will they make a movie about this like
called like podcast where it's just like
people years from now are so fed up with
this medium it's become so cringe to
them like the idea of like guys and
headphones sitting in front of a
microphone makes people as sick as
Dahmer eating someone I think as long as
people are going to be driving the cars
driving in cars or working out there'll
be something they'll want to listen to
yeah yeah I mean I guess don't know if
it's gonna be the water guys podcast
this guy came and did my water yeah and
he was like do you mind if I do a little
video and I was like what and he was
like you know my boss is 55 he doesn't
get it and they just turns the camera on
he's like okay guys what'd you see
there's a bypass valve and what's going
on another satisfied customer and he
started making content but there's guys
here we just talked about on patreon
people are making money if you're if you
work at like a job like Cold Stone cream
memory and you start making tick tocks
you can build millions and millions of
followers and one kid opened up his own
ice cream shop yeah so it can happen it
can happen everybody now has a little
bit of a chance of transcending this
hellscape with something they do by
accident yeah no the only good things
now that you can do are kind of by
accident well if you want everyone
caught up in that casino you gotta you
gotta Elevate one or two as an example
somebody's got to be like look the water
guy made it and so then that keeps
everybody it keeps everybody on Tick
Tock so then the CCP can find out all
your information
now a word from our sponsor better help
it can be tough to train your brain to
stay in problem solving mode when faced
with a tough challenge in life but when
you learn to find your own Solutions
there's no better feeling a therapist
can help you become a better Problem
Solver making it easier to accomplish
your goals no matter how big or small
I love therapy it's it's not what I
expected it's even better I feel more
like myself
what's great about betterhelp is it is
all online get matched with a therapist
after filling out a brief survey switch
therapists anytime
when you want to be a better Problem
Solver therapy can get you there visit
betterhelp.com
betterhelp.com Tim D
I'm telling you to start communicating
with a counselor and a therapist under
48 hours
if you don't hit it off you can change
it's not a big deal you don't have to
leave the house look for parking it's
cheaper than other forms of therapy
people are so happy they've done it
go to betterhelp.com timd that's better
help.com slash t-i-m-d what do you
think's gonna you think you think we're
do you think someone's gonna detonate a
nuke in do you think Putin's gonna I
hope so detonate something I hope so it
does feel a little bit like enough
already come on yeah it's getting boring
do it yeah do it [ __ ] doesn't it feel a
little bit like that it almost kind of
feels like the Trump is going to get
indicted thing you're like when right
this has been going on forever yeah it's
just it's the last yeah there's lags
forever get to it get to it we don't
have that type of attention span any
nuke it or lock them up do something but
stop or stop talking about it yeah I get
upset when they just can't stop
discussing it I'm like I just want I
want some progress right right I want
some progress right you guys have not
gotten past the idea there's got to be
some progress does zielinski make it out
of this alive
um
yeah he does I think he does you know
he's selling a book of his speeches is
he gonna go on tour with Michelle Obama
zelinski's I thought you're gonna say
Michelle wolf zelinski is selling yeah
zielinski is selling a book of his
wartime
speeches so that's what he's focused on
now that's where he's who's he wrapped
by yeah I don't know CAA I don't know I
see how what and by the way how good are
these speeches that there needs to be a
book yeah in the middle of the war yeah
the war has not been won right no there
is no in fact there's no real off-ramps
to the war it seems like we're Li we're
going towards nuclear Annihilation right
so these speeches that are so magical I
don't know what they've inspired except
they continued March towards total and
all-out War well that may be some of the
back Channel negotiations of Putin being
like hey man just let me get my book out
yeah yeah we just want to put out some
speech yeah and then you can do whatever
you want do what you want yeah do what
you want it's boring and I feel like I
you know would like to see some
resolution hopefully a peaceful
resolution but if not then nuke it's
going on too long like the Irishman yeah
it could be edited yeah yeah it needs an
editor of this war at this point I
almost sort of going I was in Romania I
almost sort of going to the Ukraine
you're gonna get tickets
I was gonna go to the Ukraine and go is
it even happening here yeah but then
people said it is they're 30 of their
infrastructure is done so I said okay
like he's hitting them hard yeah water
power they don't have Wi-Fi Putin's
hitting them now yeah he's hitting them
hard he's hitting him he's hitting him
with the artillery right it could be
Iranian drones or it could be his own
drones all I know is our media is
telling us it's Iranian drones whatever
it is yeah we don't know well because
there was that whole thing in Iran where
I don't know what that was but everyone
was posting about it that woman
in Iran something happened to her and
that was sad oh sure are you talking
about the revolution happening over
there yeah yeah that's kind of dragging
on too
what is it she had a cloak on and she
said I don't want to do it today yeah
maybe she had uh I always pronounce it
wrong
hijab on yeah you had the job on and um
well she didn't have it on what she took
it off she took it off and that's a
No-No over there you gotta keep it up
it's a known over there to take it off
over here it's a rah-rah to put it on
put it on and you're in you're in baby
Nike commercial you're getting a book
deal yeah so she took it off of what
happened acid in the face hey something
like that okay yeah who knows yeah I
mean you know it could have been acid in
the face by the way the gas digital
Producer instead of like finding
articles where this stuff's happening
he's just trying to sign into his email
he's just he's just oh there she is
that's sad well that well now you're
bumming us out we don't want that well
that's a bummer what happened what's
that
that's a big bummer she's laying there
in the hospital we're trying to do a
comedy show I'm trying to do a comedy
podcast we don't need a picture of her
in the hospital that doesn't help maybe
the sponsors won't like that we're
trying to sell underwear here for fat
people
he just maybe thought we were more
visual do we know what happened to her
good old producer do we know it's
they're saying she had a heart attack at
a police station collapsed and fell into
a coma but
that doesn't seem to be uh she died I
think that's that boy she's like there
in their in their Revolution right now
that she's like there George Floyd right
I think one whoa I think once now I get
it yeah one side's going hey she fell
and the other side's going like I don't
think she fell
what side's going like what side's going
so it's fentanyl I don't think it was I
saw a nine minute video where a guy was
going I can't breathe and you were
kneeing on his neck I think that had
something to do it well somebody sent me
him swallowing a bag of drugs oh it's
Floyd I don't know if that's true or not
nope it could be someone sent me
something yeah someone that but the knee
on the neck probably didn't help never
good never good so this woman is Iran's
George Floyd right that now you've put
it in context for me the only way for us
to understand because I never knew yes
and she had a heart attack at the police
she fell which is a real unfortunate
series of events or yeah something else
happened and that's why Iran is it's
really heating up yeah she was you know
doing the equivalent of cashing yeah so
here we go again however eyewitnesses
including women who were detained with
amini reportedly said she was severely
beaten and that she died as a result of
police brutality which is probably true
I or it's probably true depends on who
you ask or not she fell into the stairs
it could have been because maybe they're
but maybe it wasn't that right right I'm
I'm I I would guess it wasn't that
really yeah I would guess because they
don't take too kindly to uh women taking
off so you're saying she was beaten I'm
saying there's a chance there's a chance
there's a chance she was beaten yeah to
death I suspect probably yeah I suspect
there's a chance okay I'd say I'd say
that there's a good chance because
um yeah I I guess well by the way
whatever that is we're not hey you know
we're on our we we think that that is
abhorrent and it should uh be we should
we should uh do something I don't know
what we should do we should uh maybe
make another commercial about it well I
you know there's got to be a way this
would be a perfect time for Nike to make
a follow-up commercial of of her or of
something in Iran no some with how
important it is to wear the hijab to
wear the hijab yeah and play tennis or
something yeah it would be this would be
a perfect timing for it yeah don't miss
this opportunity yeah this is like the
six months right after 9 11. this is
like True Crimes and instead of just do
it when you're about to take the hijab
off Nike could go think about it
are you sure you want to do that you
don't have to it doesn't have to just do
it it could be sink it over think about
it but think about it yeah think about
it there's a lot of history there
there's a lot of tradition on your head
that you are now taking off it's your
choice put it on put it off that's
that's all you ask so the commercial
should be someone putting it on to play
tennis that's right but then you show
her taking it off yeah and she doesn't
fall into the stairs yeah or she's about
to take it off and then she starts
thinking about her mother and
grandmother right and society and that
their rules do need to kind of be in
place right and she realizes that at the
end of the day the best thing she can do
is go along with the plan right right
because sometimes that's just enough
it's a nice thing to do yeah so that's
what's going on over there that's what's
going on is that the women what was the
other thing got to be honest and this is
gonna probably make me sound like
insensitive here
it's like
you don't have to wear the full one
right no but it's like like I get what
you're saying it's like okay you guys
are a little upset you can't take them
off if you want to but we got a wage Gap
here
yeah social life everyone's got problems
nothing's perfect it's like well here's
what I I always go this isn't my culture
yeah it's this is when people get angry
at me they're like no you don't
understand it's not my culture right so
the reality is I don't tell them what to
do right because I don't it's not we're
not nothing to do with anything and also
that would be wrong of you it would be
wrong it was wrong it's pumpkin fat
Whitey tell them but here's the deal
yeah I don't go into sub-Saharan Africa
where they're lobbing off clips and
making stew and tell them what to do is
that what I would do no no Anthony
Bourdain would it would be rude for him
not to taste it he would go and eat it
yeah I just say let people do what they
do and it would be it would be what what
is it I don't medal it would be what's
it ethnocentric yes it would be
ethnocentric to assume yeah that you can
say what's right or wrong but it kind of
would I know we're being sarcastic but
here's the deal what are we supposed to
do invade no and can convince everyone
to not lob the clits off and make the
stew no what's the point no whatever
makes you happy we're supposed to
whatever makes you happy we send weapons
we have a defense industry that needs to
unload something I don't like that you
could the Ukraine was a country of white
Nazis and we've somehow made it into
like it's a RuPaul's Drag Race well but
all this sexuality was like basically
illegal there up until 20 minutes ago
when it's now the most gay-friendly
country uh of an exhale country we just
lie about what all these things are
anyway I'm but I'm sure there's a few
Nazis in Russia too for sure but Ukraine
it was like a massive thing there was
all kinds of things that they pulled
down videos it's just they're into it
yeah it's propaganda
what we should do about this thing when
they say Russians are being armed with
Viagra to rape ukrainians
that feels fake that feels like
propaganda I would sue if I was Viagra I
mean Russians are being on like they're
doing poorly on the battlefield anyway
and they're going by the way if you have
extra time go rape someone yeah that
seems like it's a little wacky well you
know there's always atrocities on both
sides it's War sure that's why I love
when people always go like hey this
side's uncivilized you're like the whole
thing as [ __ ] the whole thing is people
you know people don't know how to like
draw the line they don't go in there and
like the British have a t and then kill
you in the proper way it's like it gets
ugly it gets very ugly on both sides
well that's why we have to make some
type of deal maybe I mean we got to get
out of there we got to give a deal
there's got to be a deal gotta get a
lawyer in there get that Regent give him
those regions that he wants and [ __ ]
know NATO yeah that's what you need to
get like you know a good Hollywood
lawyer in there and say Let's Make a
Deal like a shark let's get in there
we've been preventing that you know
we've been telling you crane like don't
go to the table just keep fighting yeah
that's not great yeah we must have some
interest in it yeah we like we like
things out there do they got oil in
there I don't know they got a great
position yeah geographically and we're
we like we like slinging weapons and we
like you know but we keep we kind of
tell because like we I think we still
like telling zelinsky and everything
like hey man don't negotiate like just
you know but now Putin's like okay well
you know what we're gonna now turn up
the heat right so if we don't if there's
no negotiation that's forced you're
looking at a really bad situation
because he Putin will level Ukraine he's
going to level Ukraine and then he'll
get level it'll be bad for the whole
world it'll be bad for the world
otherwise he's dead yeah this week you
don't understand not you but people if
he goes back to his country and goes hey
sorry I wasted all the time and
disgraced us they're killing him yeah so
he his own self-preservation is like I'm
gonna try to win right we gotta win here
and it could be an ugly win yeah it
might not be a nice win it might be like
everybody's dead and there's an
Insurgency for years and everybody hates
us but we did technically win yeah so I
think you try to avoid that by making
some type of deal yeah
yeah I think uh you know I if you're
listening to this podcast Putin and
you're listening zelenski he does yeah
zelinski it's a huge Tim Duncan he's a
huge wouldn't that be funny if he was
just a huge comedy podcast fan I would
love it if he was a massive comedy
podcast or if like nothing would make me
happier if zielinski's just got time in
his little bunk or whatever he just
throws on he's such a Fame whoring guy
yeah that he's aware of every celebrity
maybe not like shitty podcast
celebrities but zielinski knows of every
Hollywood a-lister like he just wants to
be on the car I think he's been on the
cover of Vogue like well he was what he
wants to do and he was an Entertainer
before yes and he is now yeah seems like
he has one now as well because he uh he
likes the Limelight he doesn't shrink
from the Limelight he doesn't fade no no
no no he's definitely they've turned him
into Winston Churchill does this go into
World War Three you know a lot about
history apps yeah perhaps ugly yeah it
could I mean um just trying to go [ __ ]
it we're going into Taiwan China's
definitely going to Taiwan and if China
goes into Taiwan what do we have to do I
mean what do we do nothing really well
if this is the thing if it wasn't for
NATO it would have happened already
right if uh if it wasn't for NATO
Ukraine and Georgia would be leveled
already so it's like
um you know I I just don't think you
know I don't know if I buy Putin's
version that he's just like but hey I'm
upset about NATO but here's a forget
that whether it would no matter what his
motivations are he's got all the nukes
yeah so it doesn't really matter why he
did it no this is the thing it doesn't
really matter what because a friend of
mine who's a smart guy with foreign
policy was like who cares there's a
million reasons why anyone does anything
right he did it and he's going I want
these two things and if you don't give
me them I will bomb the country and if
you bomb me I have nukes and we're just
gonna go we're gonna have a party well
at some point someone was gonna hijack
the world with their nuclear capability
yeah I mean human nature hasn't changed
so some autocrat eventually inevitably
was going to do something like this yeah
so from here it either Sparks world war
three and we all go kaputsky and we
don't make it to Mars or something
happens that stops IT okay and that
something will be
a video from Hollywood why are they so
[ __ ] quiet yeah where's that video
where's that compilation video from them
saying stop
it should just be a bunch of Hollywood
actors like on set because they're all
working now yeah so they're on set and
then they just go Mr Putin stop stop it
stop it stop it it just goes from like
Amy Schumer to like you know Sean Penn
Jennifer Garner to whatever to whoever
it is yeah stop yeah Jacob a lord E from
Euphoria yeah stop it Mr Putin yeah
Zendaya stop it Keenan Thompson in there
yeah stop it I just saw him driving a
year at some Beverly Hills looks good
yeah
he's been just doing it forever he's
been around for a long time just been
doing it forever good burger wasn't
yesterday God bless him he's been out
there killing it for a long time he's
really I saw him in a Lambo truck just
smiling happy yeah he he worried about
the Ukraine yeah he ain't thinking about
it yeah
I mean good for him yeah yeah he's not
nobody really thinks about it that much
you've got back-to-back meetings errands
to run you need to pick up those last
minute sweets and treats for the
Halloween party what's the secret to
clearing your to-do list a Little Help
from doordash you get the best Halloween
candy decor and party supplies all
around spooky costume check Halloween
lights working check ready for
trick-or-treaters no you forgot to pick
up the treats go to doordash dummy
doordash they bring it to your house you
can sit on your fat ass it's good
I'm telling you right now it's so easy
to just go on doordash and get
everything you need brought to your door
from the comfort of your own home you
don't have to leave
it's so important that you get
in with doordash
don't be stupid
go down please to the thing
our listers can get 50 off up to twenty
dollar value and a zero delivery fees
when you download the doordash app and
enter code Tim d-i-l-l-o-n
our listeners can get 50 off up to a
twenty dollar value and zero delivery
fees when you download the doordash app
and enter code Tim
t-i-l-l-o-n that's fifty percent off up
to a twenty dollar value with zero
delivery fees just download the app
put in the code Tim Dillon you get 50
off up to twenty dollars that's insane
go do it now I love me undies there was
once a guy who only wore me undies
because he felt like he was wearing
nothing at all
I'm not reading that it's some dumb
Halloween thing the point is me undies
are great
everybody loves them everyone I know
wears them
um it's basically like you don't have
anything on they're super comfy you get
20 off and free shipping if you use my
code Tim I mean it is scary soft the
hype is real
if you're not impressed with me on these
the first pair is on them and that's a
promise it is so soft they have this
micro modal fabric it's crazy it's like
skin you like wearing skin
I'm telling you you cannot afford to not
do this it's 20 off your first order
free standard shipping on U.S orders go
to
meandies.comtim that's me on these.com
slash Tim it'll feel like you are
wearing nothing you will not regret it
it's a great way to support your body
the show America go to meundies.com Tim
well I'm excited about all this new all
this new stuff that's going to get made
now Netflix is bouncing back they're
kind of maybe they're they're kind of
going the other way from what they were
doing which was just really that woke
kind of annoying stuff and they're going
back to like kind of like glorifying uh
uh cannibals
and that's what I think people want and
I think that's what's gonna save the day
like I think finally you're looking at
something where people are like finally
I can sink my teeth into this literally
finally there's a protagonist I can
identify with yeah yeah yeah finally
someone who represents us sure the
non-walk yeah Jeffrey Dahmer yes yeah
yeah I mean I'm just happy about it I
think that it's going back the other way
I think that there's a pendulum swing I
think that people are really getting
interested in real stories again as
opposed to garbage yeah and the real
stories Jeffrey Dahmer's a real [ __ ]
story it did happen he's a real guy
whether you like him or not whether you
think what he did is right or not we all
have different opinions on that
it's true it's subjective really
whatever like what no matter what you
think about how he was treated by the
cops or like what is family Dynamic was
this is a real story that people can
appreciate and come to their own
conclusions right initially I think
Netflix categorized it as an LG tbq is
that true yeah and then they got in
trouble for that well it is lgbtq but I
see cannibal right I think the community
I think that Community
um got upset about that they were like
we don't want this I I we want Bros I
see what they're saying people said we
want not bro we want that I see what
they're saying but I go you I would not
mind at all you put it back under lgbtq
because it's the first good lgbtq thing
really made in recent memory yeah you
have great things like the bird cage and
stuff from years ago but recently it's
been a lot of crap yeah since that since
Brokeback Mountain well that Billy
Eichner guys this this unlovable guy
running around screaming at people on
the street he does a film it's a horror
and nobody wants this so you're saying
his movie was more of a horror than
Jeffrey Dahmer's a question
right if you had to spend five minutes
with either Billy Eichner or Jeffrey
this self-important game show host right
or Dom
the legend
but it's a game show host it's not even
a good game show and the guy's like the
guy's screaming at straight people from
not going to see the movie how about
everyone under 30 is gay if you go on
the internet right where are they at the
movie yeah he's just unlikable it's fine
it is what it is but compare him to
Jeffrey Dahmer who like it or not isn't
an instant is an American institution
yeah yes yeah it is a real story is from
the Heartland is salt of the earth has
made questionable choices
is someone who will be remembered long
after Billy Eichner has been forgotten
and Bros has been forgotten so if your
lgbtq
concerned at Netflix I'm going Dahmer
all the way as opposed to the other
garbage yeah
yeah because it is an lgbtq story
technically because there's a Ted Bundy
was a straight serial killer he was a
Playboy there's tons of straight serial
killers obviously not all serial killers
are gay
um but the ones that are why not let's
get into that let's get those stories
told let's get those stories tall yeah
it's weird because I think we are we're
almost done with the way we thought
about things for the last few years very
interesting it's folding in on itself I
think people are tired of it it's over
and the way to contextualize everything
is this overtly political very dry box
checking categorical I think people are
over that and I think people are now
really going to get comfortable in the
gray yeah this is the gray area this is
my prediction we're going back into the
gray area and the Dahmer is a great
example I would say he's I would say
it's not so great it's pretty gray
it's pretty gray what explain how it's
not gray well because he uh
he buried people and he ate them but why
do you like him
because that's what I mean I'm not
saying that was right right I'm not
saying that's not I'm saying Tony
Soprano murdered people did you like
them
um me personally do you didn't like Tony
surprise are you gonna lie right now you
[ __ ] I was married in University
[ __ ] I was more of an Edie Falco guy oh
stop yeah I identified with her story
ready Mary her struggle her story but
you know what I'm saying why do you like
that I don't like him because it was
like what did his mother do to him the
thing about him what did his mother do
to him I like we like anyone who's in
control of Their Own Story right this is
true he took the reins we like anyone
who's in control of Their Own Story this
is true and I know a lot of people are
going to be they're gonna misunderstand
this but what I'm really saying here is
that Jeffrey Dahmer do you want a world
without Jeffrey dahm no and the reality
is we don't I don't we don't we really
don't want a world with that we don't
want to get eaten no and we don't want
our friends to get eaten and it is
unfortunate it was racially based no
good yeah but we don't want a world with
a something about these monsters Keeps
Us in line there's something about these
people that we kind of like the
randomness of it all it feels there's
something about I don't even know what
it is Things That Go Bump in the night
people that disappear there's some we
love horror movies we love being scared
we love to scream there's something
about it that keeps us intact well it's
fear is fashion just the way morality
has become uh morality is fashion it's
like at a distance it's not happening to
us it's a cool safe thing you know to
say you shouldn't walk act this way when
you're around these people or you should
you know you should you should walk in
uh poor neighborhoods and just feel safe
you know and you can say that but doing
that is a whole nother thing just like
saying or watching or talking about
Jeffrey Dahmer is one thing but then
getting eaten by him is another
no one wants to be eaten by Jeffrey
Dahmer but also nobody wants that's
presumptuous I'm sure there's some some
people are [ __ ] sick Germany nobody
wants to live in a world
where it's a complete impossibility to
get eaten by Jeffrey Dahmer except for
the people who he did eat they are not a
fan that's true but they don't have a
vote but they're out they don't have a
vote but many of us like the idea when
we put our head to the pillow that that
someone's getting eaten well here's the
deal some that's true he did eat people
yes
but according to him he was not a racist
and he did not choose them because they
were bypoc right so it was fun to watch
Jeffrey Dahmer go hey hey I'm not a bad
guy I hope there's so many Dahmer
costumes this Halloween I hope people
are not dissuaded I hope people stand up
for their rights I hope people just tell
the [ __ ] people [ __ ] you I'm Jeffrey
Dahmer now if you are dressed as Jeffrey
Dahmer here's I will just say this as
sort of a safety warning like they do on
television make sure the Halloween party
you're going to is 100 white it's got to
be It's gotta be white It's gotta do not
want to show but your black friend's
party as Jeffrey Dahmer It's gotta be
white It's gotta be oh Wyatt Milwaukee
party yeah you don't want I don't dress
up you you do maybe a family costume but
I have not dressed up in years I don't
really dress up before I was married I
did not dress up yeah I just didn't I
grew up throwing eggs and getting eggs
thrown yeah that's kind of what we did
in the suburbs yeah I wasn't really uh
yeah the guy that dressed up but now
you're trick-or-treating now awesome
yeah now I'm just under the will of of
the autocrat that is my wife I'm glad
I'm glad we figured out the Iran and
Russia yeah the Persians they're
Persians you're welcome everybody yeah
and they want to be referred to as
Persian yeah well you're welcome
everybody for figuring that out I
figured that out we figured that out and
uh you know great opportunity for the
shampoo industry to get in there get in
and support the revolution well
everything's going to be and I know that
we make jokes about it but I think
everything really is going to be what
company likes your cause and what
company can promote your cause do they
pitch causes like we pick shows 100 they
go in there and they go Iranian
Revolution 100 [ __ ] I have an idea
there's a one-legged Palestinian girl
who throws the shot put
and there's 100 percent they go and they
have meanings and they try to remember
Malala yeah I remember her
they come and go yeah come and go
there's that remember Emma Gonzalez with
the shaved head from Parkland yes they
come and go oh Elian Gonzalez comes and
goes common goes Elliott page comes and
goes and goes comes back and comes back
and comes back yeah well by the way
wouldn't she be a perfect Joan of Arc if
they make that movie he sorry he he
would absolutely they would be a great
Joan of Arc no matter what gender they
identified as and I I would support it
and see it yeah I would see it there if
if
he is not cast as Joan of Arc it's a
criminal it'll be criminal and it'll be
a problem it's well is this is Jonathan
gonna happen well the whole thing is
that the TR uh there was a big movement
that she's trans I mean sorry he's
trance who's he Joan of Arc was a guy is
that what they're saying yeah they're
mad because they don't want Joan of Arc
to be portrayed as a woman because
they're saying he was he and he wanted
he was or he was one of the first it
makes it makes sense it makes sense so
they said they don't want people talking
about Joan of Arc anymore as a she
because it was clear that she was trans
is it he okay that was a big thing in
the news recently Joan of Arc Joan of
Arc was a also she was Abraham Lincoln
was gay Abraham Lincoln was also a
Vampire killer is that true yeah yeah
according to the movie oh yeah well
listen folks where can people find you
and all the things you're doing you can
find me on parlor the Greek the Greek
church you can find me the Greek church
you can find me on parlor you can find
me on only fans
that's such a great dichotomy yeah you
can see me on true social parlor only
fans
the conservative media landscape with
the new apps is wild they just eat each
other they're
interested yeah I can't wait to when
Kanye buys it what he does with it he's
well I let him buy it of course are they
gonna let the guy that owns the app
scream about the Jews parlor don't care
yeah yeah who owns like a fun like
you're at the Parlor yeah with a bunch
of guys who found it's like Steve
bannon's right no idea he needs somebody
to watch it while he's in prison yeah
he's going away for a couple of months I
can't imagine that there that uh Kanye
is gonna be able to just buy it well
according they have a deal on paper I
think yeah who's excited about that even
Executives at parlor have to go like
who's really excited about an upcoming
business deal like we said with Kanye
West the idea is gonna is more sexy even
to Kanye than the execution yeah because
once he gets on there nobody really it's
musk with Twitter he's like I'll save
Twitter it's like you're not gonna save
Twitter Twitter had a moment yeah yeah
but Twitter's moment's over like
everything else like Twitter at a moment
it was really dying before Trump trump
brought it back everything then was the
result of a a a a it all trickled down
from Trump on Twitter right everything
everything I did everything anyone did
whether it was a video or a tweet it all
was kind of in this universe created by
the fact that you had this crazy wild
guy on Twitter Donald Trump once he's
gone even if he comes back the moment's
over Twitter itself seems to not carry
as much social weight as it used to he
is really
sort of
the Frankenstein of our culture yes I
mean
you know it's ironic that Hollywood
hates him so much because they created
him well they made him what's amazing
about him to me is he's indefatigable he
means Stars won't stop yeah he won't
stop there's no signs of stopping well
because and his people don't care no
what they throw at him no documents he
had to [ __ ] new codes in the buffet
at Mar-A-Lago none of it matters no I
think it's because they also want the a
lot of his people want the world to end
yeah they're ready they're ready for the
fight they're ready for the Rapture
they're ready so anything where people
go yeah he's gonna he'll destroy the
world they go yeah yeah yeah part of it
but we want to win yeah I think he just
knows what America is about he's like I
don't care whether I'm right or wrong
what I did was true or not I don't care
as long as I'm there as long as I'm wild
you'll cut the media will cover he knows
the media he knows about he knows he
just made a great point he knows what
America is about knows what America is
about and it's like as long as I'm there
yeah and I'm wild hey look you could
even chop up and eat a whole bunch of
people yeah America will make you a star
you're going to be a star you're a star
and people are going to want to dress up
as you yeah because you Rose Above the
Rest yes and did something and you did
something and that's why it's not so
easy to just say oh we shouldn't glorify
someone like Jeffrey Dahmer because no
matter what you do inevitably he's going
to be glorified no matter what you do
it's what we're interested in and that's
what I I hope people don't lose that
because it's it's it's really it's a
beautiful story with some not so nice
parts I mean what's the difference
between Jeffrey Dahmer and like a guy
who kills one person unevently compared
to Jeffrey Dahmer I'll tell you the
difference the difference is lack of
grind the difference is Netflix right
yada's pop is everybody what's what
where can they get tickets uh just go to
giannisepapiscomedy.com I'll be an
awesome Justin
um no yeah I'll be in Austin lucky I'm
going to Republican Hollywood lucky
November uh 11th and 12th are you gonna
swim in the lake I'm gonna swim in the
lake yeah I'm gonna try to go and get a
bacteria in my vagina yeah so I'll be
there and then Detroit and she's gonna
be there on November 11th and 12th nice
yeah so uh get tickets for that uh
tickets just sound pretty well for
Austin thank you guys and uh yeah go
listen to my podcast long days go see on
his Papa's listen to his podcast long
days uh we'll see everybody soon we're
here in New York we'll be back in La
next week thank you good night